This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I grew up mainly in Ohio and in the 80s, I only knew about New York City from the movies and all the movies, every single one of them had this one establishing shot that said, audience, we are in New York City. It was a graffiti covered subway. It was beautiful. For me, a suburban kid from Ohio, that graffiti was exciting, but it didn't seem artistic or complicated.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我主要在俄亥俄州长大，在80年代，我对纽约市的全部认知都来自于电影，而且所有的电影，无一例外，都有这样一个建立镜头，仿佛在告诉观众：我们在纽约市。那是一辆贴满涂鸦的地铁。它美极了。对于我这个来自俄亥俄州的郊区孩子来说，那些涂鸦令人兴奋，但它看起来并不艺术，也不复杂。
It was just scary hooliganism. So bad you can't see. The graffiti was a total mystery to me too. Proofs and peppermint grew up in Nebraska, also far, far from New York City. It was like, Technicolor HiroGlyphics. He doing the forward Z, oh he doing his back at the front. All of these intersecting lines and colors, I mean I knew that they were letters, I just never knew what they said. New York was another planet, and graffiti was its language.
这只是一种可怕的恶棍行径。糟糕得让你看不清。这些涂鸦对我来说也是个完全的谜。Proofs和Peppermint在内布拉斯加州长大，同样离纽约市十万八千里。这就好比是“特艺色彩的象形文字”。他做一个正向的Z字形，哦，他在后面做前向的。所有这些相交的线条和颜色，我的意思是，我知道它们是字母，但我从来不知道它们写的是什么。纽约是另一个星球，而涂鸦就是它的语言。
There's only 26 letters to the alphabet, but somehow graffiti writers manipulated it, and they make it theirs. And those trains looked so cool on the outside, but the inside was a whole other story. You would not have gotten on that subway. The place where filthy, the train smelled. They were dirty. The floor, you stuck to the floor. And you got stuck in the tunnels,
字母表中只有26个字母，但涂鸦写手们不知何故操纵了它们，并将其变成了他们自己的风格。那些列车的外表看起来太酷了，但车厢内部却是完全不同的另一回事。你当年是绝对不会上那辆地铁的。那个地方污秽不堪，车厢里有异味。它们很脏。地板，你的鞋底会被黏在地板上。你会被困在隧道里，
and the car spilled up with smoke. And I mean, it was a scary place to be. In the 1970s and 80s, says this guy, David Gunn, the New York City subway was like some kind of daunting and hellscape, the fire and bloodshed and gangs. Come on! Get out of here! And there was definitely a sense that, you know,
车厢里弥漫着浓烟。我的意思是，那是一个可怕的地方。大卫·冈恩（David Gunn）这家伙说，在20世纪70和80年代，纽约市的地铁就像某种令人畏惧的地狱景象，充满了烈火、流血和帮派。少来这套！滚开！而且人们确实有一种感觉，你知道的，
the subways were totally controlled by wild gangs of teenagers and kind of were. Now all you boppers out there know that amongst the gangs there were the rogues, the grammar c-riffs, everyone's favorite the baseball furies and of course the warriors. I want you to hit everything inside. I want everybody to know if the warriors were there. Artist Caleb Neelan wields a mean spray can himself but even he admits know the warriors were there. Artists Caleb Neelan wields a mean spray can himself, but even he admits. Graffiti was simply just the symbol that the city had lost control and it was a symbol
地铁完全被狂野的青少年帮派所控制，某种程度上也确实如此。现在所有这些飞舞的小伙子们都知道，在各个帮派中有流氓帮（The Rogues）、语法黑帮（Grammar C-Riffs）、每个人最喜欢的棒球狂怒帮（The Baseball Furies），当然还有勇士帮（The Warriors）。我要你们摧毁里面的每一样东西。我要让所有人都知道勇士帮来过。艺术家Caleb Neelan自己也经常挥舞喷漆罐，但他甚至也承认勇士帮来过。艺术家Caleb Neelan自己也挥舞着一把不错的喷漆罐，但他甚至也承认。涂鸦简而言之就是城市失去控制的象征，它也是一种象征，
that who knew what the future lay with cities. It could be terrible and nothing pisses people off more than writing they can't read. So starting in the early 70s, the mayors of New York City vowed to eradicate graffiti. First, Mayor John Lindsay. He took office at really like one of the worst times for any New York mayor. Lindsay formed the first anti-Graphete task force, and he turned graffiti from a nuisance. Took it out of the category of littering or something like that. Into a crime. Into being, you know, but subway graffiti persisted. It was the problem that wouldn't go away.
让人对城市的未来充满了未知。它可能会变得糟糕透顶，而且没有什么比人们看不懂的文字更能惹恼大众的了。因此，从70年代初开始，纽约市长们誓言要根除涂鸦。首先是市长约翰·林赛（John Lindsay）。他上任时正值任何一位纽约市长面临的最糟糕的时期之一。林赛成立了第一个反涂鸦特别工作组，并将涂鸦从一种讨厌的小事。将其从乱扔垃圾之类的类别中剥离出来。变成了一种犯罪。变成了一种，你知道的，但地铁涂鸦依然存在。这是一个挥之不去的问题。
For two decades, the Metropolitan Transportation Authority, also known as the MTA, failed miserably trying to fix its graffiti problem. Sometimes laughably, like the time they decided to repaint 7000 subway cars all white. They called it the Great White Fleet. Oddly what the graffiti movement needed at that time was new real estate. And then before you knew it, you had the entire subway car covered in spray paint. And then there was Ed Koch's Berlin Wall Method. Koch doubled up the fences in the yards.
在长达二十年的时间里，大都会交通管理局（也被称为MTA）在试图解决涂鸦问题时遭遇了惨痛的失败。有时甚至滑稽可笑，比如他们曾决定将7000辆地铁车厢全部重新喷成白色。他们称之为“大白舰队”。奇怪的是，当时的涂鸦运动正需要新的“房地产”。转眼之间，你就会发现整节地铁车厢都被喷漆覆盖了。接着就是埃德·科赫（Ed Koch）的“柏林墙”方法。科赫在车场加倍修建了栅栏。
All of them topped with razor wire, thus creating a no man's land between them. Plus, attack dogs. Here's Mayor Koch. What I said, you'll two fences and have the dog run between the two fences and that will keep people out and protect the dog from stepping on the third rail. And the response was, well, maybe somebody will climb over the fence, and the dog will bite them. I said, well, I thought that's what the dog was for.
所有的栅栏顶端都装有铁丝网，从而在它们之间创造了一片无人区。此外，还有攻击犬。这是科赫市长。我的意思是，你会建两道栅栏，让狗在两道栅栏之间奔跑，这样既能把人挡在外面，又能保护狗不会踩到第三轨。当时的反应是，好吧，也许有人会翻过栅栏，然后被狗咬。我说，好吧，我想狗就是干这个用的。
And the razor wire topped fences and the German shepherds worked. Until the graffiti writers realized that they could distract the dogs with food and cut through the fences. Desperate people take desperate measures measures and the transit officials were desperate. No one knew what to do. Hello. Until David Gunn. I'm David Gunn and I was president of the New York City Transit Authority for six years. From 1984 to 1990. If transit systems had halls of fame,
这种顶端带有铁丝网的栅栏和德国牧羊犬确实起作用了。直到涂鸦写手们发现他们可以用食物引诱狗狗分心，然后剪断栅栏。绝望的人采取绝望的手段，而交通官员们已经走投无路了。没有人知道该怎么办。喂。直到大卫·冈恩出现。我是大卫·冈恩，我曾担任纽约市交通局局长六年。从1984年到1990年。如果交通系统有名人堂的话，
David Gunn would be right up in front. David Gunn cleaned up subways in Boston, Philly, D.C., and Toronto. He headed up Amtrak for a while too. He seemed invincible. But when it came to New York City in 1984, my initial reaction was no, because it was. It just looked to be a hopeless situation.
大卫·冈恩绝对会名列前茅。大卫·冈恩曾清理过波士顿、费城、华盛顿特区和多伦多的地铁。他还曾一度掌管美国铁路公司（Amtrak）。他看起来战无不胜。但当1984年面对纽约市时，我的第一反应是拒绝，因为它是。这看起来简直是一个无望的局面。
Guns actual words were suicide mission, but then his mother stepped in. At that point, she was in her 80s. She said, you better take that. Or you'll everybody will think you're a coward. Moms, you got to love moms. Gun hit the ground running with something he called the Clean Train Program. You know everybody says you're going to clean up the cars. Yeah, we did. We got the cars cleaned, but we also fixed them.
冈恩的原话是“自杀任务”，但随后他的母亲出面了。当时她已经80多岁了。她说，你最好接下这个差事。否则大家都会觉得你是个懦夫。妈妈们，你不能不爱妈妈们。冈恩一上任就雷厉风行地推出了他所谓的“清洁列车计划”。你知道，每个人都说你要把车厢清洗干净。没错，我们做到了。我们清洗了车厢，但我们也修好了它们。
The Clean Train became sort of symbolic of the fact that the thing worked. And here's the difference between you and me and David Gunn. When we see graffiti, we think about it in terms of aesthetics. We may like it or hate it, but we're reacting to it visually. David Gunn looks right past all of those wild style letters and sees a transit system not doing its job. You see graffiti you got bad maintenance because having equipment clean is part of maintenance. For decades people in charge treated subway graffiti like it was a sanitation problem. Gunn says that's all wrong.
“清洁列车”在某种程度上成了事物运转良好的象征。这就是你、我和大卫·冈恩的区别。当我们看到涂鸦时，我们会从美学的角度去思考。我们可能会喜欢它或讨厌它，但我们的反应是视觉上的。大卫·冈恩直接越过了所有这些野性风格的字母，看到的是一个没有履行好职责的交通系统。你看到涂鸦，就说明你维护不善，因为保持设备清洁是维护工作的一部分。几十年来，负责人一直把地铁涂鸦当作环境卫生问题来处理。冈恩说这全错了。
It wasn't just a sanitation problem. Gunn says that's all wrong. It wasn't just a sanitation problem. It was something else entirely. Gunn says the root of the problem was MTA's deferred maintenance program. In the 70s, New York City was broke, and the city pays for a big chunk of the transit authorities operating budget, so they asked the MTA to reduce its budget because fewer people were writing the subways. The MTA made the worst decision. They cut back on the things that kept the subways running, routine inspections, replacing
这不仅仅是个环境卫生问题。冈恩说这全错了。这不仅仅是个环境卫生问题。这是完全另一回事。冈恩说，问题的根源在于MTA延期维护计划。在70年代，纽约市破产了，而城市承担了交通局运营预算很大一部分开支，所以他们要求MTA削减预算，因为乘坐地铁的人减少了。MTA做出了最糟糕的决定。他们削减了维持地铁运行的必要开支，包括例行检查、更换
parts, even subway mechanics. And what you expect to happen happened. The subway deteriorated, breakdowns tripled, trains derailed nearly every two weeks, and get this. In 1981, there were 1800 subway car fires. 1800. Writership should go down when there's 1800 fires. No wonder David Gunn called running the MTA a suicide mission. Still, he took it on.
零件，甚至是地铁机械师。于是，你预料会发生的事发生了。地铁加速老化，故障率增加了两倍，列车几乎每两周就会脱轨一次，不仅如此。1981年，发生了1800起地铁车厢火灾。1800起。当发生1800起火灾时，乘客数量理应下降。难怪大卫·冈恩把运营MTA称为“自杀任务”。尽管如此，他还是接下了这个烂摊子。
First, he hired 1,500 non-union managers and increased repair staff. He rebuilt thousands of cars. They had new control cases, rebuild trucks, new motors, air compressors, motor alternators. All alternators. The whole nine yards. Here's the thing about maintenance.
首先，他雇用了1500名非工会经理，并增加了维修人员。他重建了数千辆车厢。它们拥有了新的控制箱、重建的转向架、新马达、空气压缩机、发电机。所有的发电机。应有尽有。这就是关于维护的真谛。
It's not sexy. It takes years to see improvements. Gun new people needed to see something now, or in this case, not see something. My approach was to drive the bastards out and to clean up the mess that made and fix the equipment. And we gradually drove the little bastards into a corner. By little bastards, if it's not obvious, gun mint, everyone vandalizing the trains. And here's how he did it. He figured out a way to do it systemically lined by line.
它一点也不吸引人。要看到改善需要花费数年时间。冈恩知道人们需要现在就看到成效，或者在这个案例中，是“看不到”某些东西。我的方法是将这些混蛋赶出去，清理他们制造的烂摊子，并修理设备。我们逐渐把这群小混蛋逼入了绝角。如果还不明显的话，冈恩所说的“小混蛋”指的是所有破坏列车的人。他是这样做的。他想出了一种按线路系统化解决问题的方法。
Again, that's Artis Caleb Neelin. Like the A line or the one line or the two line. Taking the seven line off the map for graffiti writers. While they were fixing it, they didn't allow any graffiti on it, zero. And if graffiti artists bombed a train car. Bombed, in this case, means covering the outside of the train with graffiti. If an artist managed that. The MTA pulled it from the system, even during rush hour.
再说一次，那是艺术家Caleb Neelin。比如A线、1号线或2号线。将7号线从涂鸦写手的地图上抹去。在他们修复期间，绝对不允许上面出现任何涂鸦，零容忍。如果涂鸦艺术家们“轰炸”了一节列车车厢。在这里，“轰炸”意味着用涂鸦覆盖列车外部。如果某个艺术家做到了这一点。MTA会立即将其从系统中撤出，即使在交通高峰期也是如此。
It was tough going at first. I mean, we had one day I ended up pulling 500 cars out of service. And it worked, and people knew it because they could see it. Gunn achieved the impossible. He got rid of graffiti on New York City subways. There is even an official date, May 12, 1989. People remember V.E. and V.J. Day. You know, this was like their greatest generation moment for the people who ran the subway system. This was you know, this was the their greatest generation moment for the people who ran the subway
起初进展艰难。我的意思是，我们有一天最终不得不将500辆车厢撤出运营。但它奏效了，人们能看出来，因为他们亲眼目睹了改变。冈恩做到了不可能的事。他清除了纽约市地铁上的涂鸦。甚至还有一个官方日期：1989年5月12日。人们都记得V-E日和V-J日。你知道，这就像是运营地铁系统的人们的“最伟大的一代”的高光时刻。这就是，你知道的，这就是运营地铁系统的人们的“最伟大的一代”的高光时刻。这就是，你知道的，这是他们宣告胜利的时刻。
system. This was, you know, this was the time when they were declaring victory. The Transv authority held a ceremony that day. It was up at 273 shop. That's at the end of the A-Train. All of the MTA brass and a lot of employees were there. Mirror Ed Koch was there too. privately I kidded them about the fact that I've never thought it'd see that day. And he said I was right.
交通局当天举行了庆祝仪式。地点在273号车间。那是A线列车的终点站。所有的MTA高层和许多员工都出席了。埃德·科赫市长也出席了。私底下我跟他开玩笑说，我从来没想过能看到这一天。他说我是对的。
They even made commemorative t-shirts. They were red and they had the old New York City transfer the throwy logo on them and down below it hit graffiti free in the date. But I wore it for years. It's funny now to ride the subway and imagine that there ever was so much graffiti. I mean, I've lived in New York for almost 10 years now and no graffiti covered subway has ever pulled up to my stop. I always wondered, where did the graffiti go? I thought the answer might be more complex. But this time, for once, the answer is simple.
他们甚至还制作了纪念T恤。它们是红色的，上面印着旧版纽约市交通局的标志，下方印着“无涂鸦”以及日期。我穿了好多年。现在坐地铁时，想象当年曾有过那么多涂鸦，感觉真奇妙。我的意思是，我在纽约生活了近10年，从来没有一辆贴满涂鸦的地铁开到过我的站台。我一直很好奇，涂鸦都去哪儿了？我以为答案会更复杂。但这一次，破天荒地，答案其实很简单。
You can point to a man, David Gunn. David Gunn, who I think like a lot of New Yorkers, was this, you know, white night coming in to fix the subway system. And, you know, to graffiti writers, he was this Darth Vader character. And, you know, took away their fun and ultimately was better at taking away their fun than they were at sustaining it. May 12, 1989, the day Subway Graffiti died. Okay, hold up.
你可以将这一切归功于一个人，大卫·冈恩。大卫·冈恩，在我看来，就像许多纽约人一样，是一个前来拯救地铁系统的白衣骑士。而且，你知道的，对涂鸦写手来说，他就像达斯·维达（Darth Vader）这样的反派角色。你知道，他夺走了他们的乐趣，最终，他剥夺他们乐趣的能力，远胜于他们维持这种乐趣的能力。1989年5月12日，地铁涂鸦消亡的日子。好吧，等等。
The story's not over. Graffiti didn't actually end that day. There is still subway graffiti, but because of David Gunn's Clean Train Program, it's almost become impossible for us on the outside to see. It almost never leaves the train yards. MTA crews are on patrol there constantly looking for graffiti and hosing it off with these crazy solvents that they see any. And they see it.
故事还没结束。涂鸦其实并没有在那一天真正终结。地铁里依然有涂鸦，但由于大卫·冈恩的“清洁列车计划”，我们这些局外人几乎不可能再看到了。它们几乎从不出现在列车车场之外。MTA的工作人员一直在那里巡逻，寻找涂鸦，一旦发现就用那些疯狂的溶剂将其冲洗掉。而他们确实能发现。
An international gallery of it, in fact. So the kid from Munich would go paint subways in Paris. The kid in Paris would go paint subways in Amsterdam. Graffiti writers today are kind of like Sam Collectors, hitting the Berlin's U-Bahn, the Paris Metro, and the London Tube to put into their album. Collections are judged by two things, size and value. The Subway Graffiti Completist would have to hit
事实上，这里甚至有一个国际化的涂鸦画廊。慕尼黑的孩子会去巴黎画地铁。巴黎的孩子会去阿姆斯特丹画地铁。如今的涂鸦写手有点像邮票收藏家，他们会去突袭柏林的U-Bahn地铁、巴黎地铁和伦敦地铁，把它们收录进自己的相册。藏品的价值取决于两点：尺寸和价值。一个追求完美的地铁涂鸦收藏家必须打卡
190 systems in 54 countries. And as for value, there's only one that matters. There's a real way of thinking in graffiti, which I don't think is entirely wrong, which says, you're not a real writer until you got your piece on a New York subway. It's kind of like the holy grail of all trains, you know? Right now, spray painting a New York subway car is a felony.
54个国家的190个交通系统。至于价值，只有一个标准至关重要。在涂鸦界有一种真正的共识，我认为这并不完全错误，那就是：除非你的作品登上了纽约地铁，否则你就不算是一个真正的写手。这有点像所有列车中的圣杯，你知道吗？现在，在纽约地铁车厢上喷涂涂鸦属于重罪。
If painters get caught, it could mean jail time and thousands of dollars in fines. Graffiti artists have to ask themselves, is this worth it? I'm pretty nervous talking on the microphone right now even about it because you know It's it's not really something that people are like great you're painting the subway. That's that's very nice Thank you for doing that. It's total opposite, you know This is Joe or at least that's what he wanted me to call him Joe is a graffiti artist from South Africa He hits trains and countries around the world.
如果画家被抓，可能面临牢狱之灾以及数千美元的罚款。涂鸦艺术家们不得不自问：这一切真的值得吗？我现在对着麦克风说话时感到相当紧张，甚至在谈论这件事时也是如此，因为你知道，这并不是那种人们会说“太棒了，你在地铁上画画。真是太好了，谢谢你这么做”的事情。事实完全相反，你知道的。这是乔，或者至少这是他让我叫他的名字。乔是来自南非的涂鸦艺术家。他在世界各地的国家喷涂列车。
He didn't want to say if he was going to hit New York. You can't say. I can't say. No, no, I'm not. We distorted Joe's voice to protect his identity. That's the only way that he would agree to talk to us. Joe's never been caught, but it's been close. I've looked, seen a flashlight, and turned around to tell the guy that someone is coming for us.
他不想透露他是否会去纽约。你不能说。我不能说。不，不，我不会。我们对乔的声音进行了变声处理以保护他的隐私。这是他同意与我们交谈的唯一条件。乔从未被抓过，但有时险象环生。我看到过手电筒的光，然后转过身去告诉同伴有人来抓我们了。
And when I've turned around, he's already like running. We actually caught a couple of guys from Australia just last week who were trying to breach our security and go into a yacht. And now Vincent DiMarino. He's the vice president of security for the MTA and New York City Transit transit. He sees guys from all over the world in new york's train yards. DeMarino didn't have hard numbers of who gets caught from where in the yards. But when a train gets hit in new york, the graffiti artist is more likely to be from say spain or france, not from new york. Some put the ratio at something like 80-20.
当我转过身时，他已经开始逃跑了。就在上周，我们实际上抓获了几个来自澳大利亚的家伙，他们试图突破我们的安保防线，进入一个车场。现在说话的是文森特·迪马里诺（Vincent DiMarino）。他是MTA和纽约市交通局的安全副总裁。他在纽约的列车车场里见过来自世界各地的人。迪马里诺没有掌握在车场被抓的人分别来自哪里的具体数据。但当纽约的一辆列车遭到涂鸦袭击时，涂鸦艺术家更有可能来自西班牙或法国等地，而不是纽约本地。有人将这个比例估计为80对20左右。
The international folks, it's cost them a lot of money to do. You know, if I was to get on a plane, I'd go somewhere and sit on a beach. I wouldn't buy an airplane ticket to go commit a crime and a train yacht. The graffiti artists say that's part of the draw. It's a rush to break the law. No, I want to get over this f***ing fence. It's hard to resist. It's exciting at first, you know, when you go inside to the yard and you stand on the floor, you know, on the platform and you see how big this train really is.
对国际友人来说，这样做成本很高。你知道的，如果我要坐飞机，我会去某个地方坐在海滩上。我可不会买机票去列车车场犯罪。涂鸦艺术家们说，这就是吸引力的一部分。打破法律会带来一种刺激感。不，我要翻过这道该死的栅栏。这很难抗拒。起初这很令人兴奋，你知道的，当你走进车场，站在地面上，站在月台上，你就会发现这列火车实际上有多大。
I mean, when you're on the platform, a train's a train, when you're on the floor next to it, it's like, like an iron beast, you know. I love it. It's intoxicated. The smell and the sound is so much more intense because you're already like super nervous. Luke was coming at you, what is it? There's not much that could be that feeling. It's like better than sex. Like better than money, better than anything.
我的意思是，当你站在月台上时，火车就是一列火车；而当你站在它旁边的地面上时，它就像一头钢铁巨兽，你知道吗。我太喜欢了。这令人陶醉。气味和声音要强烈得多，因为你已经超级紧张了。如果卢克向你走来，会发生什么？没有多少事情能带来那种感觉。这比性爱还要好。比金钱更好，比任何东西都好。
It's like that's how people do it. That's why someone would risk their career and their life to press the button on the spray can. They put colors on a train, you know? I see no Europeans doing it. So I'm like, why New York? Dozing doing it. This is where it's from.
这就是人们这样做的原因。这就是为什么有人会冒着职业生涯甚至生命的危险去按下喷漆罐的阀门。他们在火车上涂上颜色，你知道吗？我看到欧洲人也在这样做。所以我就想，为什么是纽约？多宁也在做这件事。这就是它的发源地。
This way it was built that like, I see, you know what? Let me bring the trains back. This is CTE. I spell it C-E-T-E and then I have a two letter C-T. The same thing means clean trains. if people don't get it. C-T tells me he always feels like an old soul, but I call him a romantic. I seen it on the trains and I seen subway art and I'm like, damn I missed this time. C-T bombed not one, but two trains this year.
这就是它的构建方式，就像，我看到，你知道吗？让我把列车带回来。这是CTE。我把它拼写为C-E-T-E，然后我有一个两个字母的C-T。同样的事情意味着清洁列车。如果人们不明白的话。C-T告诉我，他总是觉得自己有一个老灵魂，但我称他为浪漫主义者。我在列车上看到了它，我看到了地铁艺术，我想，见鬼，我错过了那个时代。C-T今年不仅“轰炸”了一列，而且是两列列车。
The first was the art train. It was a spy versus spy theme. It took about 11 cans and an hour to paint. But days and days of preparation. I studied these lines. I studied the times. I even studied down to the workers because if you could find a lazy worker one day
第一列是艺术列车。它的主题是“间谍对间谍”（Spy vs. Spy）。这花了大约11个喷漆罐和一个小时的喷涂时间。但前期准备长达数天之久。我研究了这些线路。我研究了时间表。我甚至研究了工人们的作息，因为如果你能找到一天偷懒的工人，
and you could do a lot of stuff. In this MTA, they have a lot of lazy workers. The second train they hit was a B-train, this time with a pink panther theme. We had the whole day planned like recon mission. And here's what ties CT and David gun together. Both men that spent a lot of time scrutinizing the weak points in the MTA system. CT dreams of bringing back New York subway graffiti. But the number of hits are rapidly declining.
你就能干成很多事。在这家MTA里，有很多偷懒的工人。他们袭击的第二列车是一列B线列车，这次的主题是粉红豹。我们像执行侦察任务一样规划了整整一天。这就是将CT和大卫·冈恩联系在一起的地方。这两个人都花了很多时间仔细研究MTA系统的薄弱环节。CT梦想着让纽约地铁涂鸦卷土重来。但袭击事件的数量正在急剧下降。
In 2007, there were 75 yard hits. So far this year, only 9. The MTA's police force can take some credit for those numbers, but there is another factor. I find it hard to think of graffiti writers who were much under 25. And a lot of the most active people that I know are in their 40s, honestly.
2007年，发生了75起车场袭击事件。今年到目前为止，只有9起。MTA的警察部队可以为这些数字归功，但还有另一个因素。我很难想象有哪个涂鸦写手在25岁以下。老实说，我认识的许多最活跃的人都在40多岁左右。
Graffiti is an art form may just age out at some point. And if subway graffiti did die out, how would we even know? The artists know that their work will never be seen by the public at large. They break into the train yard, paint their murals, and immediately after this subway cars are scrubbed clean by MTA workers. The art form is totally ephemeral. It reminds me of those Tibetan sand mandalas made to disappear. If you think you're just going to live forever, it's not.
涂鸦作为一种艺术形式，可能在某个时候会面临年龄断层。如果地铁涂鸦真的消亡了，我们怎么能知道呢？艺术家们知道他们的作品永远不会被广大公众看到。他们闯入列车车场，绘制壁画，紧接着，这些地铁车厢就会被MTA工人擦洗干净。这种艺术形式完全是昙花一现。这让我想起那些藏传佛教的沙曼荼罗，注定要消失。如果你认为自己会永远活下去，那是不可能的。
Everything you do would turn into sh** one day. Pretty much all that keeps that from happening right now is social media. There are invitation only Instagram accounts where subway bombers post their work before it disappears. Those painted trains that crossed our movie screens on countless establishing shots of dirty New York City in the 1970s. They are just a little square on your smartphone now. And by the time you see them, they're already gone.
你所做的一切终有一天会变成狗屎。目前阻止这一切发生的基本上只有社交媒体。有一些仅限受邀加入的Instagram账户，地铁“轰炸手”们会在作品消失之前将其发布到上面。那些在20世纪70年代充满脏乱差的纽约市的无数电影建立镜头中穿梭的彩绘列车。现在它们只是你智能手机上的一个小方块。等你看到它们时，它们已经消失了。
My love is the trains. There's always going to be trains to the casket drop. There's always going to be trains. And yeah, that's a body. Let's roll. Until the casket drops or until the NYPD Antigraphy Unit, called the Vandal Squad, catches up to you, which is what happened to CT. He was arrested and charged with more than 180 misdemeanor counts for things like possession of a graffiti instrument and intention to damage property, along with some felony charges. He took a plea deal, agreed to pay nearly $19,000 in restitution charges, and is now on probation. 99% and visible was produced this week by Ann Heperman, with help from Gulliabarton,
我热爱列车。只要棺材还没入土，就永远会有列车。永远都会有列车。是的，这就是一具尸体。我们走吧。直到棺材入土，或者直到纽约警察局的反涂鸦小队（被称为“破坏小队”）抓到你，这就是CT的遭遇。他被逮捕并面临180多项轻罪指控，罪名包括持有涂鸦工具和意图破坏财产，此外还有一些重罪指控。他接受了认罪协商，同意支付近1.9万美元的赔偿金，目前正处于缓刑期。本周的“99%隐形”由安·赫帕曼（Ann Heperman）制作，并得到了古利娅·巴顿（Gullia Barton）、
Roby Flores, Sam Greenspan, Katie Mangle, Avery, Trophamon, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio, KALW and San Francisco, and produced at the offices of Arxign, the coolest architecture firm in beautiful graffiti adept downtown Oakland, California. If you like fun, you can keep up with this show and all the people who make this show. At Facebook, Twitter and Tumblr, but if you want to see the Spy vs Spy subway car, it is amazing. You have to go to 99pi.org.
罗比·弗洛雷斯（Roby Flores）、萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）、凯蒂·曼格尔（Katie Mangle）、艾瑞里·特罗法蒙（Avery Trophamon）以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）的协助。我们是位于旧金山的91.7地方公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽且充满涂鸦的市中心、最酷的建筑事务所Arxign的办公室里制作。如果你喜欢有趣的内容，可以在Facebook、Twitter和Tumblr上关注本节目以及所有制作本节目的工作人员。但如果你想看那辆“间谍对间谍”的地铁车厢，它真的很神奇。你必须访问99pi.org。
This is the last stop on this train. Everyone, please leave the train. Thank you for riding with MTA New York City Transit. Radio Topee-O. From PRX. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是这列火车的最后一站。请各位下车。感谢您乘坐MTA纽约市交通局列车。来自PRX的Radio Topee-O。来自PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。